haben wir gerade das sprichwort und
wiegt gehört noch mal ganz kurz
ihr klang eben schon an dass hier von
mietern die rede ist das weiß man dort
entschieden zurück wissen sie wie die
durchschnittliche rendite nettorendite
nach abzug aller kosten und steuern ist
in deutschland für vermied werden
vermieterin bei zwei prozent etwa genau
ist es darin redlich noch von miet
einzusprechen mietwucher es gibt doch
immer dieses schöne stichwort der see
war im schnitt 1 meter tief aber die kuh
ist trotzdem ersoffen und das sagt ganz
gut das aus was wir auf dem
wohnungsmarkt haben
der durchschnitt also mieterinnen und
mieter wohnen nicht in einer
durchschnitts wohnung sondern sie wohnen
in einer wohnung und sie haben sich
auseinanderzusetzen mit der situation
die sie vorfinden und deswegen haben
leute die bei acteos zb in berlin wohnen
wo wohnungen aufgekauft durch saniert
und dann der preis zu sehr hohen preisen
die sind ganz andere ganz anders dem
ausgesetzt als leute die bei privaten
kleinst vermietern sind wo zum teil seit
zehn jahren gibt es auch in berlin keine
miete erhöht wurde oder bei einer
marzahn hellersdorfer genossenschaft
oder so natürlich gibt es unterschiede
und deswegen muss man sich dem buch
sozusagen zu wenden und den rausholen
und nicht pauschal alle ab bayern die
eigentum haben im wohnungsbereich es
sind nicht alle das problem und private
kleinst vermieterin vermieter sind zwei
drittel der eigentümerin und eigentümer
und viele von denen sind sehr sozial
sind weil sie zum teil ja selbst sogar
zur miete wohnen während sie anderswo
fern dass über eine sehr schöne
überleitung zu frau bekam nicht pauschal
abmahnung genau da hätte ich hier das
bka sie sind selber klein vermieterin
und außerdem auch noch tätig bei haus
und grund das ist ein verein der sich um
die interessen von vermieterinnen und
vermieter kümmert sie haben hier schon
die ganze zeit aufmerksam zugehört wie
oft haben sie sich denn mitgemeint
gefühlt wenn jetzt von den gierigen
vermieterinnen und vermieter an die rede
war zeitpunkt wirklich zu keinem
zeitpunkt also insofern finde ich auch
sehr sehr wichtig also ich habe schon
mit vielen anderen seit langer zeit auch
darüber nachgedacht wie man das machen
kann dass man spitzen und und
dinge die einfach verkehrt sind und
unschön sind dass man die stoppt aber
dass man nicht alle damit trifft und das
problem ist der mieten deckel trifft
leute wie mich genauso wie diejenigen
die verantwortlich sind für dinge die
unschön sind und aus meiner sicht wäre
es tatsächlich notwendig mal generell
sich gedanken darüber zu machen
über grundlegende werte grundlegende
werte die auch bei regierungswechseln
nicht über bord gehen sondern
grundlegende werte immobilien sind im
mobil- und es ist aus meiner sicht
essentiell wichtig für alle beteiligten
für die mieter ist es wichtig für die
vermieter ist es wichtig für diejenigen
die die investieren ist es wichtig dass
man über sehr lange zeiträume
verlässliche rahmenbedingungen hat die
auch so ausgestaltet sind dass sie
zukunftsorientiert sind und mieten
deckel gehört in jedem fall nicht dazu
also der mieten deck ist aus meiner
sicht ja hat keine wohnung geschaffen
geschadet geben wir das doch direkt mal
weiterhin die rund 100 sie haben den
mieten deckel unterstützt das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat gesagt er
ist nicht in ordnung hat den mieten
deckel kassiert allerdings nicht aus
inhaltlichen gründen sondern weil das
gericht gesagt hat die länder sind nicht
zuständig der bund ist zuständig die spd
sagt jetzt okay dann machen wir es halt
im bund sie schlagen jetzt war es etwas
anderes vor ein sogenanntes mieten
moratorium in zwei sätzen was ist der
unterschied zu mieten moratorium ist ein
kompliziertes wort wir nennen es mit
stop umgangssprachlich was wir wollen
ist das in angespannten wohnlagen dass
es dort wo heute schon so was wie die
mietpreis bremse greift das dort für
fünf jahre mieterhöhung maximal
inflationshöhe möglich sind und wichtig
dass wir diese fünf jahre dann aber
nutzen um den bezahlbaren neubau an
dieser stelle anzukurbeln weil sonst
gucken wir nach fünf jahren unterm
strich was rausgekommen sind es hat sich
ja gar nichts verändert und dann sind
wir tatsächlich in der endlos spirale
die sie beschreiben wo es keinen
gesunden wohnungsmarkt in zukunft geben
wird
apropos was rausgekommen ist gucken wir
mal auf die kurzfristigen folgen von
mieten deckel hier in berlin letztes
jahr sind die mieten noch mal um 12 etwa
im schnitt hochgegangen
das angebot an wohnungen hat sich
reduziert um etwa 50 prozent weil viele
eigentümer gesagt haben
da werde ich meine wohnung schnell noch
besser verkaufen wie wollen sie denn
verhindern dass genau diese negativen
folgen
auch bei ihrem moratorium kommen naja
schauen sie sich an was die treiber für
diese entwicklung gewesen sind erstens
haben wir ein heftiges umwandlungs
geschehen in berlin von miet in
eigentumswohnungen werden in den letzten
jahren über 50.000 frühere mietwohnungen
verloren die jetzt in eigentum
umgewandelt wurden weshalb wir immer
gesagt haben wir wollen natürlich
gleichzeitig auch schärfere umwandlungs
regelung die haben wir jetzt gerade in
der bundesregierung wir hätten sich
gerne noch schärfer gehabt aber wir
haben sie durchgesetzt in berlin wird
künftig gelten dass ab drei wohnungen
die man besitzt man einen genehmigungs
zwang hat man muss sich genehmigen
lassen dass man umwandeln davon den
meisten fällen wird diese genehmigung
nicht erteilt werden damit wir mit
wohnungsbestand schützen so was braucht
man auf der einen seite und natürlich
muss die kapazität insgesamt wachsen es
ist ein ziemlicher ukrainer dass in der
stadt mit einer knappen wohnungsangebot
natürlich auch nach einem mieten deckel
nicht plötzlich der markt geflutet wird
es fehlt an wohnung aber das sollte der
mieten deckel auch nie lösen er ist
regulation bauen ist ein anderes erst
aber das nicht lösen aber sollte sich
auch nicht dazu führen dass die
schlangen vor den verfügbaren wohnungen
noch länger werden oder dafür sind ja
auch weniger leute im gegenzug verdrängt
worden es ist ja relativ logisch dass
weniger wohnungen am markt angeboten
werden weil nicht mehr so viele leute
wie vorher wegen einer steigenden mieten
aus ihrer früheren wohnung verdrängt
wurden aber es war doch gehört auch zur
wahrheit mit das war doch noch viel
schlimmer ist doch in wahrheit ist es
doch so was kommt von so was man verirrt
sich in einer sackgasse und läuft immer
tiefer rein wir haben eben doch was hier
feststellen sie maßnahmen hat 80 prozent
sagte mich weiß nicht ob also die euro
politik nicht wird die hat hier unsere
und bürger ja aber vielleicht darf ich
erklären wozu geführt hat darüber reden
wir ja hier
wir haben doch eben jetzt gerade gehört
zwei drittel der vermieter sind
kleinvermieter sind nicht die großen
konzerne
daneben gehört die durchschnittliche
rendite von vermietung ist alles andere
als finanzhaie was da gemacht wird aber
gleichzeitig läuft auch hier heute
teilweise diskussionen sind die profite
das problem in wahrheit reden wir über
grundlagen der sozialen marktwirtschaft
und das ist eine ablenkung von dem
realen problem wenn man feindbilder
sucht und das ist das falsche wenn man
mit den grundlagen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft spielt
dann wird es am ende nicht besser ist ja
nicht nur so dass der mieten deckel die
schlangen zur wohnungssuche länger
gemacht hat und es noch schwieriger
gemacht hat eine wohnung zu finden
sondern auch der neubau die
neubautätigkeit in berlin ist
eingebrochen weil wenn man sich eben auf
diese grundlagen nicht mehr verlassen
kann 2019 fertiggestellt und wenn er so
dahin
genau dann zu hören dass ich seit jahren
über 1900 berlin 2009 10 beim pro kopf
jahr über an hamburg vorbei gezogen hat
sich in den deutschen verbänden
berlin gesetzlich entschuldigung ist es
einfach die anderen berliner
stadtpolitik hat aktuell tut sie was für
neubau 2009 10 das ist richtig zur zur
fraglichen zeitpunkt des mieten deckels
ist die neubautätigkeit eingebrochen und
natürlich muss man ja auch jahrelang
versäumte polizeiwachen 71 jahre lang
regiert hier in berlin seit 20 jahren
das zu verantworten hat dass dieser
mangel von euch geschaffen wurde
dann bleiben wir dann werden wir noch
mal ganz konkret sie beschreiben das
problem sehr schön die frage ist bei in
so einer notfallsituation
welche maßnahme welche begrenzung des
mag das kann sich denn die fdp als
sofortmaßnahme vorstellen ja also
erstens tragen sie ja lenken sie die
frage ja schon wieder sozusagen weg von
der lösung des problems vielleicht reden
wir darüber erstmals eine akutelle ja
genau ja aber das ist ja aufgebaut warum
ist in berlin denn die situation
schlechter als zum beispiel in hamburg
weil man jahrelang schlechte politik
gemacht hat also wenn ich da wenn sie
nach einer lösung frage liegen warnte
heute gerne gleich auf die frage wir
vielleicht ganz kurz in der sendung auch
darüber reden was denn zu tun wäre
wir können das ist die lage eine
sofortlösung für die mieterinnen und
mieter die jetzt gerade suchen seit
jahren sind wir also erstens müssen wir
in der tat mehr bauen das kannst du das
eigentliche vorteil könnte man auch ja
das ist aber die das ist wenn du
aufhören willst an symptomen
herumzudoktern sondern auch die ursache
an gehst dann wäre es vielleicht
sinnvoll dass wir nach darüber der
hälfte der sendezeit darüber auch mal
reden bei einer sendung groß um die
soziale frage wohin geht so und da geht
es natürlich um bauland wenn wir berlin
reden wir sind in berlin neukölln da ist
den letzten zehn jahren die mietpreise
um 150 prozent gestiegen gleichzeitig
haben wir riesiges gebiet auf dem
tempelhofer feld wo man bauen könnte und
auch stärker in die höhe bauen wir
könnten günstiger bauen es wurde gar zu
recht schon erweckt wir können das
das muss man auch das ist richtig so
kurzfristig müssen der zum beispiel
menschen wie frau ziegler helfen indem
wir uns die frage stellen wie können wir
individuell die menschen beim wohngeld
zum beispiel stärker fördern das ist
eine hilfe das eve dann ihr ganz konkret
zum beispiel in münchen wir reden ja
nicht nur über berlin
also wir subventionieren die renditen
nein die subvention ähnliche renditen
wir unterstützen menschen helfen
menschen
denn dabei wohnraum raus käme genau
guckt mir doch mal konkret oder vielen
dank für den hinweis wir wollten ohnehin
noch die werden nicht glauben
tatsächlich auf das thema kommen zwei
wochen bauanleitungen fördern
vielen dank bauen bauen bauen das ist
ihr credo und eine idee dabei ist die
grunderwerbssteuer anzupacken sie wollen
dann freibetrag bis zu 500.000 euro in
ein zwei sätzen was ist die idee
dahinter also der freibetrag bei der
grunderwerbsteuer setzt nicht nur bei
der frage wer mehr bauen an sondern der
als insbesondere ein instrument das
dafür sorgen soll dass wir ein volk von
eigentümern schaffen dass wir mehr
menschen die möglichkeit geben das
wünscht sich die mehrzahl der menschen
in unserem land wenn sie es wollen eben
nicht ihr ganzes leben zur miete zu
wohnen so und wir haben ganz konkret das
problem dass der staat nicht nur problem
treiber bei der bautätigkeit ist dann
auch kostentreiber bei der frage wie
kann ich mir vielleicht als junge
familie nach ein familien haus oder eine
eigentumswohnung leisten weil sie zum
beispiel wenn sie eine durchschnittliche
immobilie kaufen der deutschen großstadt
noch den gegenwert eines kleinwagens
obendrauf legen nur für den staat das
verhindert auf die immofinanz ist eine
hübsche idee für gagen diese leben
hübsche idee sondern ist veränderung der
sozialen situation in unserem land wäre
es wenn es denn so käme ist die idee
sage ich deswegen weil sie mir nicht
ganz neu vorkommt ich habe schon mal
gelesen im koalitionsvertrag von nrw
2016 haben sie die zusammen mit mit der
cdu da reingeschrieben passiert ist in
den letzten vier jahren nichts da kann
ich ihnen genau sagen warum weil das
land nrw das leider nicht darf die
grunderwerbsteuer ist so konstruiert
dass die länder zwar den satz festlegen
dürfen aber sie dürfen keinen freibetrag
einführen es sei denn die bundespolitik
ermächtigt sie dazu und ich will ihnen
ganz genau erklären daran sehen sie auch
unseren ansatz
hier könnte man die grunderwerbsteuer
senken das kostet mehr den start und sie
fördern gleichzeitig aber auch
denjenigen der 10 15 wohnungen hat und
möglicherweise erwirkt
aber wenn es darum geht dass wir
familien die erste eigene immobilie
ermöglichen sich freibetrag natürlich
viel besser weil dann gar keine
grunderwerbsteuer mehr darauf aber herr
vogel dann wurde deutschland nicht im
koalitionsvertrag eine sache rein
schreiben bei der sie mit in den kader
ohnehin nicht kommen und zweite phase
konnten wir ja vielleicht die frage ja
dass sie sagen selbst die die
grunderwerbssteuer in der höhe hätten
sie senken können die ist aber nirgendwo
in deutschland höher als in nrw und
schleswig holstein zwei länder zwei von
drei ländern in denen sie mit regel ja
genau die hat aber in nrw auf diesen
satz die rot-grüne regierung erhöht
wir haben von anfang an gesagt wir
wollen diesen freibetrag weil der
freibetrag dafür sorgt dass junge
menschen junge familien sich eine
wohnung steuerfrei leisten können und
was im koalitionsvertrag konkret steht
bitte dann auch ganz korrekt zitieren
ist dass die landesregierung nrw einen
grund eine bundesratsinitiative
einbringen wird um den ländern das zu
erlauben das hat er mehrfach getan wird
abgelehnt die große koalition mehrfach
und uns sagen was wert abgelehnt die
große koalition ist dieser gerhard
veränderung erfolgt das fassen wir jetzt
auch mal hier zusammen denn was ich hier
bei allen raus höre ist dass natürlich
alle wohnraum wollen und dass bauern
eine sehr gute lösung wäre
[Musik]